Monday is introducing a new SUV to its
model range but unlike the Tucson and
Santa Fe the new Kona is classified as a
small car our tester Emmanuelle Shaffer
knows it will face fierce competition he
says in the booming small car segment
SUVs are as common as grains of sand at
the beach so for a new one to stand out
from the crowd there must be something
special about it
and with the Kona that's its design the
Cunha scores points with its striking
good looks big blank wheel houses really
show off the light alloy wheels which
can be as large as 18 inches
[Music]
at the sides it's dynamic lines are
complemented with matte silver accents
[Music]
the crossover has 361 litres of trunk
space which can easily be expanded to
1143 liters by folding down the rear
seats twin taillights round off the rear
end and the sloping roofline merges
seamlessly into the roof spoiler some
island and ice markers rick says the
cone is a real SUV with its own platform
and all-wheel drive it's not just a
packed up high 20 it's a true SUV with
an attractive choice of gasoline engines
120 or 177 horsepower with a dual clutch
transmission since the cone is so small
the 177 horsepower engine can propel it
from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour in 7.9
seconds so it's great fun we're testing
the more powerful version of the Kona
with a 1.6 liter gasoline engine and 130
kilowatts of power that allows the
crossover to hit a top speed of 205
kilometers per hour
amano says the kona is really pleasant
to drive and smooths out the effects of
uneven ground while it's not the
sportiest of vehicles and rounds curves
well at speed it's a bit too loud for
his taste but not excessively so meaning
that you can easily drive it for long
stretches and the all-wheel drive does
have its advantages in adverse weather
conditions so you always have good
traction by vegan vet abiding woman
visitor in town to helps fall and
bouncing torch and gallon by melting hot
money midi best attracts on the corners
exterior design is also reflected in the
car's interior including the color of
the paint job
[Music]
the enrollment the manhwa thinks that
the interior is very nice-looking and
well arranged all of the buttons you
really need can be found here on the
steering wheel but the highlights are
the accents around the air vents and on
the gearshift and the seat belt to match
though the SUV is small leg and Headroom
in the back is more than adequate Kona
again Chris Rick says that the kona
extends the company's SUV range they had
the large size Tucson and the mid-sized
Santa Fe but they didn't have a small
SUV even though this is a growth area
and customers were asking for one so
naturally they wanted to enter this
segment with an attractive vehicle and
he's pretty sure it'll take the market
by storm submission of Walden Amano says
it's not just the conus design that's
what we're looking its drive systems
aren't - Hyundai plans to introduce an
all-electric Kona with a range of up to
400 kilometers later this year and you
can't wait to test it it's a nice punt
off